hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the Just Cause series is renowned for
its sheer volume of Easter eggs and
cultural references from reoccurring
appearances of our snowman nemesis we
meet again Bustos snowman to sci-fi
moments like the weeping angels from
Doctor Who
Just Cause 4 is no different so let's
dive in and look at 21 Easter eggs and
secrets you should find while exploring
solis by the way loads of these Easter
eggs are continuations from Just Cause 3
or earlier I'll link that Easter Egg
video here if you need a little reminder
of past references anyway let me know
which is your favorite Easter Egg for me
it has to be number through Easter Egg
there's always one weapon in Just Cause
that is perfectly pointless and
ridiculous we had the big head weapon in
Just Cause 3 but just cause four is
ready to top of that head over to Viper
knees and find this farm just above a
populated area on the porch should be a
cow print weapon on the ground pick it
up and go crazy shoot everyone you can't
hurt them so don't worry because this
happens honestly I couldn't complete any
missions after finding this weapon I
spent so long just doing this I need a
life only by accident did I realize that
by using the weapons alternative fire
mode turns Rico into a damn sexy heifer
why the heck is this in a game just
cause I suppose don't change just cause
you're brilliant the way you are
remember back in Just Cause 3 we met
this perp at the rubbish dump and he
wouldn't stop following us around well
he's back in Just Cause for he hangs out
this bridge we crossed at the start of
the game but that's not the end of this
Easter Egg in Just Cause 3 returning the
pooch back home to his kennel rewarded
us with Doge mode what is my problem I
can't find the mutts home and Just Cause
for I mean I spent five hours looking
around this death-trap village with no
look I did unscrupulous things to the
mutt in my frustration sorry Dougy
anyway no one has found the end of this
easter egg yet so jump in and you could
be the first to find it thanks to Drew
Andrew who informed me the pup is back
anyway onto the bigger stuff
the next Easter Egg is an 80s
masterpiece back in 1984 a Norwegian
synth pop band released a single called
take on me the accompanying video used a
combination of animation and real life
and at the time it was mind-blowing and
yeah the song was pretty good too well
over in Vista Futura you will see a
building made construction venture
closer and you'll hear the first line of
that music intake on me
[Music]
jump down the stairs to be part of the
80s again I'm gonna switch out the audio
for legal reasons but if you want to see
me find the Easter egg and completely
embarrass myself I'll throw a link up to
that now the thing I'm so embarrassing
another long-running Easter egg in that
just cost series revolves around the
floating airship named the mile-high
club if you don't know what that means
I'll let you google it
just remember to delete your search
history afterwards that ship crashed and
then Just Cause 3 the debris-filled the
ocean as if you haven't guessed already
the mile-high club has returned in Just
Cause for it isn't back in the clouds
just yet but it's damn close in the
North section of a minha you'll stumble
across this promiscuous Club there's
more Easter eggs inside as the rave
scene in Just Cause 3 is back again the
DJ is none other than bolo Santo Z from
Just Cause 2 my name is bolo Santo Z I
am the leader of the revolutionary army
known as the Reapers back then we worked
with her to take out a dictator in Pinal
which leads to yet another Easter Egg
look at the sign on her decks / now
Sonic I know you already get the pun but
heck I'll break it down anyway / now
like I've said was the setting of Just
Cause 2 and Pinal sonic is also a play
on words with a tech brand Panasonic
gotta love those puns before we leave
there's one more easter egg in the rave
and yet again it's a returning character
from Just Cause 3 the Green Man dancing
at this disco is taken from a TV show
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia and
the alter ego mascot created by Charlie
Kelly yeah just see for yourself
Green Man is saving your life right now
bro
help me out here has he changed the
color is mauve soo or is it still green
some people say that this looks blue I'm
not sure oh here's a completely weird
and strange thing to have in the world
there's a moon floating above the ocean
I do not travel to the northwest of the
map and you'll find it for yourself
you're not the first judging by that
flag but still something I wouldn't have
expected that moon can also be found in
the mall James Bond inspired secret
villain base imaginable if you haven't
finished the campaign it can be a little
difficult to reach this without being
shot to pieces but it is possible
climbing up this mountain you'll find a
rock with an X upon it
destroy that rock and it opens up a
secret lunar facility
whenever I went there it was absolutely
pitch black but there are people working
inside
things get weirded though by breaking
the skylights and venturing out into
space what can I say
perfectly ridiculous
there's a regularly occurring mariokart
reference in Just Cause in Just Cause 3
our friend Mario took a soap box karting
and this time around it's Donkey Kong's
Jeep we need to discover it's in the
village above the football stadium or
monster truck stadium if you prefer it's
a little difficult to handle but my word
it's a faster booger look at it go
hopefully you're better with it than I
am as we're talking about vehicles
already that just cause traditional
number plates returned once again with
the name of the game and the developing
studio just caused an avalanche hidden
in plain sight
[Music]
No
[Music]
ever watched a comedy that has a
laughter track in built to tell people
when to laugh well Rico can activate his
own over by the funfair is a secret
hidden pollster that only can be seen
after removing the refuse container here
is a freakish clown by shooting its face
we can activate the laugh track to test
it out
smash headfirst into something and now
you need to decide if they're laughing
at you
or with you on a side note when Rico
uses the balloon function on enemies
he'll occasionally say this flies you
fool
straight from Gandalf in Lord of the
Rings your fruits during the development
of justice for the game which took over
the world was none other than pub G
player unknowns battlegrounds is
referenced in Just Cause for over an
abundancy ax is a small town with a
random frying pan on a building go on
pick it up it's a melee weapon it acts
the same as Rico's whip so the hit
detection is a slightly bit off still
done fun to use on civilians in
particular once we found the pub G
reference we all try to find a fortnight
reference to salute the game which
usurped its predecessor over in Han
Paris you will find a pinata many people
believe this is a fortnight reference
but I'm not sure there was pinata
missions the game and thinking on it
could be the missing pinata from Just
Cause 3 anyone remember the mime artists
in the woods let's throw another old G
Just Cause referencing for good measure
there's a scene in Apocalypse Now in
which the attacking US troops fire upon
their enemies in a fleet of attack
choppers the music played is none other
than flight of the Valkyries since the
original Just Cause Rico occasionally
breaks into song when firing from a
helicopter and yep is the plight of the
boundaries
let's stick with movies for the next two
references ever watch the Jurassic Park
or Jurassic world film I'll show you how
in the north east of the map a dinosaur
facility is ready to be discovered the
logo matches the design and the mosquito
locked in amber which starts the movie
series the cage itself could be the
t-rex pen from the og movie or maybe the
Raptor cage from the updated movies
which do you think it is to compound
this reference further is the terminal
nearby it needs the generator turning
onto you and when Rico attempts to hack
it will get this route hot this once
again references Jurassic Park and the
protected computer samuel l.jackson is
trying to unlock here's one I simply
can't decipher up in the mountains are
these statues of ibex they're
indestructible I don't know what to do
with them they look like low polygon
models or even origami I suppose the
best I can find in the real world our
statues found in the Alps mainly in
Austria but there are some in Sweden
where Avalanche Studios those base
tenuous I know what do you think I need
healthier what could these
indestructible statues be reference to
just cars likes to include memorials to
friends and families of their creators
and developers Jessie for continues this
loving trend over in tallada there's
dozens of names here and they all range
in age and some have questionable names
saying that so I believe that they may
be pets other people though have lived
great lives long lives
Philip er in particular who lived to an
impressive 92 and was a teacher I'll
settle for that I really will Easter
eggs like this help us remember previous
generations and for that I think it's a
great idea to include them in video game
form I know that was quite somber so
let's finish on something a little more
upbeat and damned frustrating - there's
an indie game named getting over it with
Bennett for
a game about a man inside a cauldron
platforming with a Yosemite hammer
whilst Bennett fadi commentates and
gives pearls of wisdom it's hard to
understand but it's in Just Cause bought
and here's what happens when you find it
this Easter Egg is a homage to a game
which is a homage to a free game that
came out in 2002 titled sexy hiking why
did I make this I could have made
another silly weapon or pop-culture
reference most people like those but not
everyone's the same
I created this Easter Egg for a certain
kind of person to hurt them when most
people see a fuel tank they want to burn
through it quickly a quick fix for the
fickle quick dynamite sticks for the
feckless but that's not me I'm a
Destruction acrobat blowing stuff up I
savor that Rico Rodriguez now I know
you're most likely watching this Easter
Egg online where someone else is
discovered and recorded it for you like
a baby bird being fed chewed up food
don't worry
that's culture too playing Just Cause is
like constantly teetering on the edge of
chaos actually there is no age to Teeter
upon Mario Frigga okay I quit before I
finish the course so I have no idea what
happens at the end of it it's far too
stressful for me so that's my list of 21
there is one missing and I know you all
know what it is I couldn't find mr.
snowman I've been searching for over a
week and I've even gone to the extremes
of asking the developers but they won't
reply to me mr. snowman has been here
since Just Cause 2 and I'm certain he's
in the game this time round we shall
wait and see I suppose if you find it
first anyway you'll be the first in the
world so what other things did I miss on
this list I'd love to know your thoughts
I'm Adam from Playstation grenades it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]